it's already been announced that
watchdogs too won't have Ubisoft's
trademarked our climbing mechanic now
watch dogs 2 game director Danny
Belanger has told gaming bolt that it
won't feature the AR minigames from the
first watchdogs either I'm Lucy and
welcome to your I'm in GameSpot news
update
Balaji said AR games from watch dogs are
not returning we are offering more City
exploration so as you're walking around
the city you'll open nethack and you'll
discover operations and secrets that
will unlock side quests if you want say
our games in watchdogs included nvz n
and cash run in n VZ n each shoot AR
aliens with a plastic while cash run had
you running after coins and dodging red
skulls the digital trips were another
set of minigames where the player would
be thrown into one of four different
worlds however it's not clear if these
will appear in watchdogs - but don't
worry we've contacted Ubisoft
to clarify we got the opportunity to
play watchdogs - III GameSpot Scott
Butterworth said I definitely
encountered some silliness during my
hands-on time including some out of
touch pandering to Millennials and some
laughable abuses of Technology but
overall watchdogs - looks promising its
world is sunnier in more ways than one
it's hacking appears to deliver on
promises left unfulfilled by the
original game and honestly the
soundtrack so far is impeccable with any
luck the final product will live up to
its e3 demo when the full game launches
this fall it was confirmed to e3 the
watchdogs - would let you play through
the game without killing anyone and that
PlayStation 4 players would get all the
DLC first watchdogs - releases for ps4
Xbox one and PC on November 15th so are
you gonna miss watchdogs AR games let me
know in the comments or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on watchdogs - keep it GameSpot